hallo leute heute sind über einen pool
denn
[Musik]
adam hall dance manchmal herausfinden
wollte was ist für alternativen zum
fitnessstudio gibt ich gehe ja selber
seit anfang des jahres uns wird das
studio das mache ich zusammen mit meinem
freund timo und da sind wirklich gut
dafür ist zweit machen weil wir uns
immer gegenseitig pushen
und morgens dann losfahren ich kann aber
auch verstehen dass viele von euch
schreiben des fitnessstudios vielleicht
auch langweilig sein können oder wenn
man alleine geht ein bisschen einsam und
nicht so cool und um einfach mal eine
andere fitness welt kennenzulernen wenn
ich zum news poledance gegangen und bei
lilly mal einen grundkurs zu machen
lilly hat er vor dem studio in 2018
gegründet und gibt dort zusammen mit
ihren trainerinnen verschiedene kurse
und selber macht es schon seit vielen
jahren und als wir sie in action gesehen
haben merkt man einfach was für eine
absolute körperbeherrschung wie hat und
man sieht ihr einfach die leidenschaft
für diesen sport auch an
ich packe euch mal alle ihre social
cindy infobox und dann könnt ihr euch da
mal durchklicken und euch auch in sie
verlieben so wie ich und jetzt geht es
erstmal los mit dem kaffee dann starten
wir mit dem bein etwas weiter gefüllt
als die hälfte kommt tief runter
[Musik]
aber wir kannten die handgelenke nach
oben bleiben
[Gelächter]
ich persönlich dachte man geht sofort an
die stange und macht die übungen dran
aber natürlich müssen die muskeln
erstmal warm werden und dafür gab es
verschiedene übungen
ihren fans herausgekommen das aber
eigentlich ganz gut wenn man schon aber
ich bin schon den war also ich bin schon
so ein termin ende weist die stadt hin
und weg ist
jetzt wird alles gut ist und beim warmup
gab es auch schon die ersten sexy mudrow
ich gemerkt habe dass dieser sport nicht
nur was mit kraft zu tun hat sondern
auch mit dass tätig
ich habe mir noch nie in meinem leben so
elegant bewegen müssen und ich glaube
mir sieht man das auch an das ist echt
neuland für mich war in meinen wird
gestritten
aber genau seitlich
nach unten und kombos wieder hoch
und jetzt gerecht und dann wären wir
hochziehen links runter also ein großer
erfolg
[Musik]
welche die beide kommen zu groß die sehr
gut als bist du mal
[Gelächter]
und jetzt wo unsere muskeln warm sind
und ich eigentlich schon fix und fertig
und nach hause gehen wollte geht's dann
jetzt richtig los lilly macht hier in
ihrem studio verschiedene kurse also man
muss gar nicht sofort alles können man
ist nicht mit leuten zusammen die das
irgendwie schon salzen viren machen und
silber und nein überhaupt nicht
überhaupt nicht die meisten kommen
hierher und haben gar keine wirkliche
trainingserfahrung oder erfahrungen im
bereich tanz oder toren akrobatik fangen
dann in level 0 an interpol den macht
man drei bis fünfmal auf jeden fall und
dann schaut man auch mal ein bisschen
länger an dem kurs bleiben möchte oder
schon ins nächste level geben möchte
okay und wir machen jetzt aber erst mal
so ein bisschen grund genau wir machen
das was wir einen typischen intro focus
auch machen würden eher lernen die
grundtechniken das heißt gelaufen die
poli machen die erstens ein klein
bisschen floor work also sachen auf dem
boden und zum schluss gehen wir noch mal
an die pop und machen den ersten kleid
den ersten sitz und dann gehst du am
ende mit einer kleinen curio hier aus
dem raum wird dann club präsentiert wenn
die nächsten stange nicht ansehe dann
lasst uns loslegen wir beginnen links
neben der pol eine fußlänge abstand
schließt die beiden leben und wenn man
so weit wie möglich oben raus greifen
fest zu die schulter aus amour du ziehst
dich einmal hoch aus dem arm raus und
dann sehen wir uns einmal raus mit der
hüfte und in ein paar schritte um die
potenten linke fuß setzt von rechts die
sind nicht
inzwischen schritt machen einen schritt
vor der zweite fuß leidet hinterher und
schießt
gleich auf der anderen seite mit dem
blick zum vorhaben die reifen mit der
linken hand hoch der rechtehandel löst
wir drehen uns um und schauen wieder
nicht
ist gleich auf der anderen seite
versucht dich aus armkraft hochzuheben
um wir gehen los der rechte fuß setzt
vor links leidet und schließt
weil das so gerne sexy marx nehmen wir
jetzt auch noch einmal den rahm würzen
der slider hoch von der hüfte zu
schulter geht am kopf vorbei zum linken
ohr
am nacken vorbeizulenken
die linke hand löst wird drehen uns zu
paul
spiegel
erhöht man verbindet der pole dance
natürlich sehen die man aus
hollywood-filmen kennt wo die frauen
sich sexy einer stange räkeln und ganz
ehrlich als ich das erste mal neben der
stange stand hatte ich total das
selbstbewusste und sexy gefühl
ich habe mich noch nie verlangen wir
echt sexy bewegt und je wir starten
einmal mit einem tipps finden tipps
bietet sieht folgendermaßen aus
du steckst ein äußeres fein raus das
linke bein in diesem fall du spürst den
zug im arm gefallen nach vor amazonen
großen kreis mit dem linken bein rom
ersetzen der stand by und bleiben mit
dem stadtbahnhof gas genau du hast ja
die stärksten wagen der welt ja aber ich
glaube nicht dass können den krienser
hefte raus sein
[Applaus]
und dann gehen wir in den nächsten muss
und zwar ist es der backspin mache ich
zeige ihnen einmal kurz vor
[Musik]
okay wenn ich mal auf die rechte seite
der pole 34 mit der linken hand auf
kopfhöhe rechte hand greift der anteil
hoch die beine öffnen und dann bringst
du die pohlheimer deine axel rein umarmt
sie ganz fest mit der linken auf dem
linken ellenbogen aber zuhörer elf
wochen so brust sie die polin dem boden
rein gib deinen linken fuß an nun
versucht den rechten mit ansehen die
zehenspitzen börse je
dafür noch ein bisschen stärker haben
rechts geht ran füße zusammen für sie
berühren
[Gelächter]
und schaue was ich schon mal zu den
übungen sagen kann es macht mega viel
spaß es macht auch süchtig weil man
immer besser sein möchte und die form
und die choreografie immer besser
ausführen möchte aber es ist so
anstrengend und
wenn man dabei sieht wie sie sich an der
stange festhält und eine übung ausführt
denkt man sich erstmal ja okay dass das
mache ich jetzt auch aber mein
unterstützt es wirklich was die muskeln
da eigentlich leisten ich konnte mich
nicht mal richtig an der stange
festhalten und dabei paar sekunden dran
hängen also der ganze körper wird da
gefordert und man merkt einfach wie viel
arbeit da drinsteckt dass man so eine
körperbeherrschung auf entwickelt und
dass die muskeln sich so entwickeln dass
man sich so gut daran festhalten kann
und diese übung ausführen kann also sind
wirklich auch ein sport wo man immer
besser werden kann und ich glaube das
ist auch so ein bisschen das ist nie
wirklich aufhört spannend zu sein und ja
dass man erfolge sieht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich dachte die stange dreht sich immer
einfach mit und deswegen dreht man sich
überhaupt
naja das ist eigene kraft je weiter du
dich mit der hüfte heraus schiesst umso
mehr energie kannst du nichts bin rein
bringen ja werden so weit rausziehen am
anfang und dann daran kommt wie man mehr
umdrehungen das zweite dass das äußere
bein so lange wie möglich gestreckt und
erst wenn du fällst siehst dich impuls
artig zurück
wo ist eigentlich zusammen
bodenarbeit jetzt
mitte rechts und links an die pole und
gehen jetzt einfach in dieser position
zum boden sowie wir landen werden ja wir
versuchen auch wieder mit dem blick nach
vorne zu lange die füße leiden jetzt
nach links und wir setzen uns hinter dem
rechten fußgelenk die hände vom nach
hinten das linke bein sieht man halt
tragen dann nehmen wir uns weiter zurück
und machen den fans aus dem warmup
genau wollte dass unsere beiden sehr
schön dann drehten wir uns um anlegen
und auf dem dach postiert
seien über den boden und zurück
am
boden lassen mit dem team will auf einem
hohen level gehoben wird stetig zurück
die fußgelenke und rohrhof andere dann
greifen wir zu pro geht einen schritt
mit links setzen uns aus fußgelenk man
schritte rechts sind in der haut der
patienten raus arme sind
[Applaus]
nochmal
[Musik]
daher dass wir nicht immer ist gut ich
habe die choreografin nicht so gut
hinbekommen es war aber die erste stunde
willi hat mich gelobt und das reicht mir
sehen verlags diese beinbewegung habe
ich gelernt es ist wirklich sehr sexy
wenn man so hart ich war die ganze zeit
auf zehenspitzen net es war es so
anstrengend aber
der
stress alle einzelteile der choreografie
gelernt also zu realisieren lernen
konnte und jetzt versuchen wir es mal
verändern also job den wir machen jetzt
coole musik und dann sieht es richtig
gut aus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
ich glaube man wird ja einfach immer
besser oder also man kann immer mehr
greifen und die oft macht man so einen
kurs am besten also als anfänger man es
reichte teil aus wenn man am anfang
einmal die woche kommt ja und dann ab
einem gewissen level macht es schon sinn
zwei mal die woche zu kommen zwei oder
drei mal wenn man dann immer noch besser
werden möchte also habt ja gesehen wie
die kugel aussehen soll und für das
erste mal weiß ich gar nicht mal so
schlecht oder aber sie zeigt auf jeden
fall
[Musik]
fr
lasst uns leben
statt
[Musik]
ich stütze
ja
okay das
tor
[Musik]
kopflos
geschlagen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
warum sollten die leute zum pol denn sie
gehen also ich hab jetzt schon gemerkt
das macht mega spaß aber was ist die
faszination dahinter also die meisten
sollte die suchen erst war irgendwie
sich für eine work art weil die wissen
wo denn das anstrengende workout dann
kommen die hierher und finden eigentlich
so eine leidenschaft die unglaublich
süchtig macht die finden hier eine
community neue freundschaften die
kriegen inkompetenz bewusst und haben
einfach nur super viel spaß dass das
habe ich auf jeden fall gemerkt das
macht unglaublich viel spaß bundesrat
das macht ein bisschen süchtig immer
wieder ein bisschen besser zu werden und
es vielleicht dann doch zu schaffen das
war schon krass es wird auch irgendwie
sowas sehr spielerisch ist das erinnert
irgendwie den körper auch so ein
bisschen dran dies ist auf dem
spielplatz oder sich auszuprobieren
gleichzeitig fühlt man sich aber sehr
erwachsen sehr viel wie nehmen sehr
weiblich und ja es ist echt mal was
anderes und es hat irgendwie sich findet
mitbringen so alles zusammenkracht
ästhetik also ich finde das es in
schwarz vollends hat ist ja immer das
stück heißt es einfach auch so
athletisch und sind sport und her sehr
gut also leute gibt es ein tool denn
meldet euch hier gleich an
ich habe auf jeden fall ließ aussagen
kommen wir unterschreiben dieser sport
macht so viel spaß und ich glaube es ist
wirklich was für das gesamtpaket für die
psyche für den körper einfach für das
ganze selbstbewusstsein und wenn man das
gefühl hat h ich komme nicht so ganz aus
mir raus dann ist das wirklich die
perfekte challenge also wenn ihr ein
studio in der nähe haft dann guck doch
mal davor bei macht vielleicht meine mit
probestunde vielleicht sogar news
poledance und sagt ihr auf jeden fall
dass ihr von mir kommt und ja wir sehen
uns beim nächsten video wieder mit einer
weiteren sportart würde ich mal sagen
das wird auch ganz
ja bist dann leute abonniert main kanal
gibt vielleicht im video auch einen
daumen nach oben weil das mein kanal
ganz gut und wir sind uns das jetzt mal
wieder biss dann ok